[Music]
hello
i'm ben mosby your host for tonight and
i'm delighted to welcome you to the team
bridge sports and community awards
which is brought to you virtually for
the first time
ever as you can see even though i'm
presenting from home
i have dressed up for the occasion and
hope you have too
don't found the charts uh we've got
loads of people to showcase and
recognize tonight in a range of
categories
and i'd like to take this opportunity to
thank each and every one of you for your
hard work and dedication
to making team bridge such a special
place to work live and play
before we start the awards and introduce
you to the finalists i want to pass you
over to james cross from our headline
sponsors at kitson solicitors
who's kindly put together a few words to
welcome you to our first ever
virtual awards evening hello my name is
james cross
and i'm the chairman and partner of
kitson solicitors welcome to the
teambridge
sports and community awards for 2020
this year brought to you virtually and
organized by the splendid
teambridge district council this year
we're bringing the awards to you
digitally so that allows us to go out to
thousands more people through social
media
and other platforms this is our chance
in 2020 with
co-19 the awful situation we have all
have
to celebrate once again the great
community we have
and to thank and recognize
all the volunteers the sports people
that go to make our community
a fantastic community thank you to
everyone
who's played a part in pulling these
awards together
the nominators the nominees the
charities the schools the teams
and the communities that have tirelessly
worked for the community of team bridge
and for the judges for judging we
couldn't do it without you
in no particular order you will surely
see on your screens
an introduction to our finalists and
their incredible achievements
in each of the 12 categories please
ensure that you have your volume
up on your device or you'll miss all the
important details and announcements
do enjoy the first ever virtual awards
evening
brought to you by team bridge district
council
and kitson solis visitors thank you
james
so let's begin the show with three
champions
in the community who volunteered many
hours and achieved
extraordinary results to inspire our
residents
to be healthy and stay active
the first category is in recognition of
an individual
or a team who's shown true dedication to
a sport
health or community within the team
bridge district
from september the 15th 2018 to january
the 15th
2020 the finalists for the sport health
and or community champion are aaron
clark
michael and jillian wright and trainer
talk south devon
now let's go to a short video
presentation to find out
why they were nominated for this award
[Music]
[Music]
aaron clark aaron is the founder of
mental health muscle
a not-for-profit organization started
here in newton abbott in january 2018
off the back of the suicide of a young
man from kingston afc
called kyle deakin which shocked the
local community aaron is also chairman
of newly established football team
mental health muscle united
raising awareness of mental health and
suicide prevention supporting local
charity king's care and the hashtag do
it for deaks campaign with kyle deakin
at the heart of the aims and core of the
group he's a passionate professional who
puts everyone else before himself
and is a role model for many he started
a movement which quite literally is
saving lives and his legacy is truly
incredible his passion and energy to
promote positive mental health awareness
of it and the power of exercise
is there for all to see and has allowed
him to lead a movement that has been so
impactful and relevant for so many
people
building better community understanding
of mental health and mental struggles
and by using the gym to help and create
better resilience and education
aaron is an inspiration to the many he
supports and works with
michael and jillian wright michael and
jillian are volunteers at the kurzweil
care memory cafe and deliver weekly
health walks for the community as part
of the walk this way programme they are
long-term volunteers at king's kirswell
library and were instrumental in
stopping the closure of the library
they organise an annual fundraising
coffee morning for macmillan
michael helps at the local church and
fate to raise money for the village and
church and he's also a bell ringer
in addition he supports mrs wright with
her volunteering work and fundraising
events
both have lived in the village all their
lives and they're keen to keep the
community spirit thriving
train the talk south devon trainer talk
south devon is a running group
established in 2018
by head coach danny page and run leaders
sam and steve page
head coach danny page is a level 2 coach
in uk athletics and a guide runner for
the visually impaired in 2018
trainer talk offers a couch to 5k
program and a mixed ability running club
the team of coach members to achieve
huge personal best records at park run
events across south devon
a total of 31 runners have completed 81
events at torbay vela park alone as one
example
the team has supported and trained
members in their first 10k events and on
half and full marathon training
trainer talk south devon is linked with
the devon girls can campaign
they hold monthly park room meet-ups and
runs away from home this is a very
supportive and encouraging club which
celebrates everyone's personal
achievements
and the exponential growth of the club
demonstrates the team's success and
achievements
[Music]
and the winner is aaron clark
congratulations aaron and to all our
finalists in this category
a big thank you the next category
is the personal achievement award this
category
recognizes an individual who's achieved
a personal goal in the local community
such as overcome a fear or defy the odds
exceeding their expectations and
achieved success
within team bridge the finalists are
julie dingley antoinette eid
and bradley oliver let's hear all about
their achievements
before we announce the winner
[Music]
[Music]
julie dingley julie tells us her story
in her own words
ten years ago i had no confidence no
self-esteem and no sense of purpose
my life was made up of daily visits from
carers gp appointments and regular
visits from the community nurse
my epilepsy hasn't gone away but how it
affects me and how i cope with it
is what's changed i've been volunteering
for the past 10 years at tinmouth
hospital for volunteering for health we
have a loyal dedicated team of
volunteers who provide transport for
patients
something that i feel very proud of is
that i'm now doing 10 hours of paid work
with volunteering in health
i'm involved with the hope program which
teaches us how to become empowered
and it helps us set goals for ourselves
in november i even did a 15 000 foot
skydive with my colleagues
volunteering has made me feel valued and
part of a team today my life is good and
i no longer see myself as a disabled
person
but i'm a small cog i'm one of over 200
volunteers in our community and we're
making a difference to people's lives in
timmouth
antoinette eid antoinette went through a
bit of a bad patch in her life
and found herself being talked down from
the multi-story car park
she went on facebook saw someone was
speaking about andy mann's club
and that's how she found out about the
women's well-being club in her own words
she said
i went in with a friend for two months i
wouldn't speak i'd sit at the back
a friendly face came in one day and
looked over at me eventually i started
to speak and i just said my name
then everybody clapped on the sixth or
seventh week i spoke and then i didn't
shut up
i've had a traumatic upbringing i was in
care from a baby i've had 20 odd foster
families but they couldn't deal with me
i was blonde haired big blue eyes quite
a sweet little kid but inside
i was damien's daughter then i got
fostered to a couple
they split which traumatized me all
along i was always looking for my mum
i got the london phone book and called
up to speak to someone i have never met
he traced my mum she wasn't what i
expected it was my mum
i had an image of a mum i gave her a
chance she tried to give me some money
which i didn't take
she was more interested in being in the
pub one of my sisters didn't know me
my dad died two weeks before i met him
it messed me up quite a bit
one of my aunties told me my mum had
gone to the dominican republic
i hadn't heard from her then the police
came to tell me she's been murdered out
there
then i had press outside my house this
wasn't a good time in my life
since i joined the women's wellbeing
club and i eventually started speaking
i'm now facilitator it's somewhere you
can moan but not be judged you can be
yourself
the club gives me somewhere i can
offload the pressure has gone you feel
free
it's better than taking a pill to reach
out and help someone is the biggest
reward
anybody can take a pill to mask their
issues but get out there and talk about
what you're going through
and what makes you smile thank you to
women's wellbeing club for the chance to
speak
out it's thanks to them that i am no
longer suicidal or depressed
bradley oliver bradley is a real fighter
bradley was born with multiple lifetime
chronic health conditions
as he has got older we understand them
better though his medical team from the
nhs say they're still learning so we all
have a long way to go
bradley has to be careful about getting
too hot and struggles in the sun
so the ice rink is perfect for him it's
just a shame we don't have a rink in our
backyard he has to pace his day and can
only do a maximum of two hours of mental
and physical activity in 24 hours when
he uses too much energy at once or puts
his body under such high stress he knows
recovery time can be a long time and he
has to miss his skating for three weeks
as a result
sometimes more unlike most his skate
he's unable to practice as much to
master his routines
his heart races all the time he suffers
anything up to 300 ice pick head pains
every day as part of the side effects
as a result along with his other health
issues he becomes very fatigued
and this is why he is a regular user of
a wheelchair everyone who knows of
bradley can see he's a true inspiration
in october 2019 bradley became one of
sport's england spaces for devon helping
to raise awareness in the new campaign
hashtag we are undefeatable put forward
by plymouth pavilions
bradley in september became national and
international champion gaining first
place gold competing in both the british
junior inclusive ice skating
competitions for jeans 2019 physically
independent as well as the international
championships junior inclusive ice
skating competition for jeans 2019
physically independent level 4. bradley
defies the odds every
day the doctors can't understand how
he's doing what he does with all his
health problems
bradley is so determined bradley's
brother ryan was quoted as part of his
nomination saying
i'm very proud to be able to call
bradley my brother i find it almost
unbelievable that with all his ailments
and how he suffers daily he's willing to
put himself through more and achieve
such great things
[Music]
the judges had a very difficult time
trying to decide upon a winner for this
category
and for the first time in history
we're delighted to announce that the
winner is
all three finalists so a big
congratulations to julie
antoinette and bradley you've all won
the title
of the personal achievement category
let's all raise a glass
or a cup of tea or coffee which is
probably what it is isn't it
um and say congratulations to all three
of our extraordinary winners
right there team bridge district
council's priorities
include tackling climate change and
adopting a greener district
so for the first time ever we're
delighted to include the new category of
green champions this category
is brought to you in recognition of
individuals
groups and also organizations for their
achievements and changes
made towards environmental issues
sustainability
and climate change across the district
from september the 15th
2018 to january the 15th 2020.
the finalists are dualish against
plastic
gorilla gardening group kyron
white og wild
plastic free newton abbott stuart molson
sustainable bishop teeny's green club
tim murph recycled art in the landscape
or trail
let's have a look at what they've been
doing to make team bridge a more
environmentally friendly district
dualish against plastic dualish against
plastic applied to keep britain tidy for
50 free stainless steel drinks bottles
for display and sale on dualish against
plastic stalls and gained plastic free
community status for dollars from
surfers against sewage
this included encouraging local
businesses to remove certain single-use
plastic items from sale or use
and work in conjunction with other
community groups the group have
organized a beach clean each month with
up to 40 participants at any one time
rubbish has been removed from beaches in
doris including broken glass
sharps rusty metal and a kitchen knife
doris against plastic has assisted two
local schools and a group from exeter
college with beach cleans
dallas sainsbury's managers met with
members after their staff had voted to
support dap as part of their community
involvement during their 150 years
celebration staff attended beach cleans
and the local store collected money for
dap
they worked with doris community college
and gatehouse school to create a train
made from recycled materials for doris
carnival the group continued to attend
meetings and spread the message about
plastic free initiatives throughout the
local community making a difference to
the local area
[Music]
guerrilla gardening group at the end of
alexandria terrace there's a patch of
grass on a very steep hill which has
never really been used last year some
residents of the street
started working to transform this space
they'd done some gardening work put up
fences
and old tyres have become benches and
minions and plant pots
there's even a dog poo bag dispenser
they got other residents involved by
making wooden bugs
and asking the children on the street to
decorate them so that they feel involved
with the garden
residents have helped by donating plants
digging and making well-deserved cups of
tea
it's become a lovely welcoming community
space that has helped to bring residents
together
not content with just this one area
they've moved on to clear up the lane
behind the street
removed weeds and shrubs from the road
to create more parking which is in high
demand so close to town
and improved another patch of garden at
the other end of the street
kieran white kieran is a year 12 student
at coombs head academy who is very
environmentally minded
he tries to do a litter pick in his
local area or his route to and from
school at least once a week and will
also rally his friends to do a group
litter pick every couple of months
he takes the time to think about the
areas that are looking littered when
choosing where to litter pick rather
than just cleaning the same route all of
the time
back in may 2019 he contacted the waste
and cleansing team at the council to
borrow litter-picking equipment for a
litter-picking event that he'd arranged
for the explorer group that he's part of
and made all of the arrangements for the
event
in the last year he's spoken to younger
scout groups about the environment and
taken them out on litter picks as well
in addition to his passion for litter
picking and keeping the local area clean
and tidy he's also put together a
petition to try to reduce or remove the
amount of plastic packaging in local
schools and supermarkets
he has both an online petition which is
in the region of thirteen thousand
seven hundred signatures currently and
in paper form which has over one
thousand signatures that were gathered
by kieran and friends from his explorer
group when they stood in newton abbott
town center
he's hoping to carry on the momentum of
the petition and go to local schools
with it to raise awareness
this is a fantastic achievement and
shows dedication to the important issue
of the environment
especially when he also took his gcses
last year whilst doing all of this great
work
og wild og wild was set up in july 2019
by a group of volunteers in ogwell to
make use of verges and other green
spaces to plant wildflowers and trees to
help local wildlife and improve
biodiversity
at all well roundabout they've cut and
cleared the edges to tidy up and ensure
a good showing of the anemones that come
up in spring the bench on the village
green has also been renovated
a small orchard has been planted behind
doors closed play park consisting of
five apple trees and one mulberry a
flower bed was created and planted on
the corner of larks meade way and ogwell
road
ogwell road and canada hill has been
cleared of scrub and brambles and
planted with cyclamen the smaller part
of the village green was cut
cleared scarified and yellow rattle sewn
to begin the process of conversion into
a wildflower area
plastic-free newton abbott plastic-free
newton albert started in april 2019
organizing litter picks and raising
awareness whilst joining the plastic
free communities campaign
led by surfers against sewage becoming
one of over 500 places across the uk who
signed up
the project coordinated by transition
newton abbott and supported by community
action groups promises a joined up
approach to further reduce unnecessary
single-use plastics
it requires a community-wide effort to
bring people together to speed up the
eradication of unnecessary plastic
pollution
and stem the plastic tide they organized
two litter picks at newton about key and
the town centre
and they even had people in the water on
canoes and along the river and canals
classic free newton abbott has worked
very closely with the south devon
university technical college
utc and their eco ambassadors and the
school is now their plastic free hub
the group visited several primary
schools in newton abbot spoke in their
assemblies
and presented the schools with a book
about duffy the turtle which discusses
the consequences of plastic pollution in
the seas
they are planning more events together
with action for climate team bridge and
hope to unite the whole community in
newton abbott and hopefully achieve
plastic free status in 2020
stuart molson stewart is a member of the
team bridge trotters running club
the club organizes five running races
throughout the year we provide food at
all of the events
as you can imagine these occasions
create a lot of rubbish in the past we
would have put the lot in the normal
waste disposal
stewart took the initiative to research
a better way to dispose of the waste
he contacted team bridge district
council and arranged to collect separate
wheelie bins for cardboard
plastic and general waste he collects
them before each event and returns the
bins after the event
ensures that the bins have been used
correctly
sustainable bishop sustainable bishop is
going through a bit of a revival
we relaunched at the bishop stanton
festival in june 2019.
they are interested in a sustainable
greener future and their interests cover
everything from organic gardening to
upcycling
ethical investing to green energy
transport sharing to environmental
protection
and enhancement to name but a few they
hold some interesting talks but they
also want to take action create projects
so far the group have held one very
successful repair cafe
and have another one in two days time
they are also planning repair kids
sessions where children are encouraged
to tinker with
and fix broken things they have started
bishop eco baggers
who are turning waist curtain and duvet
fabric into tote bags using the morse
bag design
the fabric bags are available at the
village shop supply stores
and are helping get rid of plastic bags
they also run a community allotment
and run community gardening
[Music]
tina's green club tina's green club was
created by students at teen school in
september 2019.
since then they have formed links with
tree planting community groups
audited teen schools website
investigated ways the school community
can be more green a formulating a plan
with team bridge and woodland trust to
plant 1000 trees
provided tutor materials for the rest of
the school community to educate about
climate change
attended climate change forums in exeter
to ensure young people's voices are
heard
and a fundraising at school as part of
climate change action days
[Music]
tinmath recycled art in the landscape
tinmath recycled art in the landscape or
trail as they are known
started out as an annual exhibition
event and the sculpture trail goes from
strength to strength
but as the climate crisis has become
more pressing and the science clearer
we have found ourselves engaged more and
more in learning
education and collaboration with partner
agencies
on a year-round basis art and
particularly
sculpture remain at the heart of all we
do but over the years
the trail artists collective knowledge
around environmental issues
and how to make art from recycled
materials has given us a unique set of
skills
that are increasingly in demand outside
of our annual exhibition
the more we were learning about plastic
from our partner agencies
the more concerned we became armed with
a passion to make a change
we decided to get ourselves an education
in plastic
we researched many avenues and decided
to become trained
as eco brick trainers with the global
ecobrick alliance
and to open a terror cycle point we
pursued these options in the hope that
educating consumers on single-use
plastic
would in turn exert consumer pressure on
businesses to change the products
and packaging they sell
[Music]
the judges decided upon two winners in
this category so please
put your hands together for kyran white
and sustainable bishop
congratulations to all our green
champion finalists and thank you for
your hard work and dedication
to our local communities the next
category
leads us to the more active side as we
recognize the coach or manager of the
year
for the district's sporting communities
this category is in recognition of an
individual
who's led a team a squad or individuals
to success in the sporting or community
setting
from september the 15th 2018 to the 15th
of january
2020 and the nominees
are james trout
ryan bugard and chris ratterbury
let's have a look at what they've been
doing to earn themselves a place
in the final
james trout james runs a successful
tennis club at the king stanton tennis
club called kingston lobstars for young
people who have down syndrome
james first became involved with the
down syndrome association when his
employer the environment agency hired a
person with down syndrome
james is a buddy to tom in his job
helping and guarding him on a daily
basis
the tennis club is very proud that tom
has now become one of the volunteer
coaches
tom became one of the first people with
down syndrome to complete the lta
coaching qualification
to raise awareness and funding for the
down syndrome association james and matt
rayner
replicated the longest match in history
playing for 10 and a half hours and 189
games
the event raised 1400 pounds the down
syndrome association now has four active
sessions running in devon in addition to
tennis there are two football sessions
and athletics
they hope to soon also include sailing
everyone is very proud and grateful to
james for all that he does for the
charity
both in his workplace and in his spare
time
ryan bugard ryan won coach of the year
for devon from the lawn tennis
association in january 2019
and was invited to the presidential
lunch by the lawn tennis association in
june of the same year
ryan is a devon coach as well as
coaching his own academy
at bobby tracy tennis club he runs
school programs in the team ridge area
and is a hard-working and dedicated
coach for children
and young people from bobby tracy and
surrounding areas
chris rattenbury chris is a coach and
volunteer at king's boxing club in king
stanton his dedication to coaching
boxing at the club is outstanding with
an 80
win ratio from ordinary young people
many with behaviour related and personal
issues
chris is a role model and a social
worker as well as a coach
almost four years ago chris rescued a
run-down vandalized boxing club in an
area that was full of anti-social
behavior
drug taking and criminal damage within
two years of opening the gym it has gone
from nothing to one of the best boxing
clubs in devon
the club continues to evolve and is
producing amazing results for young
people who choose positive and healthy
lives
the club has produced more champions and
is competing at regional and national
level
chris is regularly featured in the mid
devon advertiser and local press with
achievements of his regional and
national champions
chris's passion and commitment and drive
is unlike any other from one man and
helping young people to live their dream
[Music]
and the winner is chris rattenbury
congratulations chris and for all of our
finalists for their amazing achievements
we're now moving on to a more
educational theme as we announce the
finalists of the community school
of the year award this award
is in recognition of a school or college
that has shown commitment dedication and
success
in sport and or community engagement
and the nominees are coons head academy
sheldon primary school wallbrook primary
school
let's see what they've achieved above
and beyond their normal
and busy school activities and whilst
you watch this video
i'm gonna go and put my dog in the
lounge
[Music]
[Music]
coombs head pe department kum said pe
department has set up primary sport and
pe provision for all local primary
schools they've been running gifted and
talented clubs for local primary schools
and their own students whilst providing
the sporting spectacular event for all
local primary schools coombs head has
offered top-up swimming for pupils and
continues to provide a range of
opportunities for pupils to engage
in pe and sports
sheldon primary school sheldon primary
school is working with the local
community particularly
supporting intergenerational work with
the ongoing pen pals project with
volunteering in health
each pupil in year six has been matched
with the lonely and isolated person from
the local community to write to and the
pen pals are invited to school once a
term to meet each other this has helped
to reduce loneliness
and also to break any stigmas that the
different generations may have about
each other
pupils from all ages at the school also
visit a local care home once a week to
further build these bridges between the
generations
the school is focusing on their pupils
health and well-being with their
learning
journey this spring term being can we
make our community a blue zone
as part of this pupils enjoyed a day
where they got to try at hula hooping to
remind them that exercise can be fun and
it's not all about winning
also the celebrity chefs the happy pair
gave a talk about healthy eating and how
to
be happy some of the staff are even
taking part in a plant-based challenge
along with local healthcare
professionals to see how this impacts
their health and will be looking to
offer more healthy options on their
lunch menu
as a result walbra primary school walbra
primary school have achieved
extraordinary results with their
extracurricular activities in school
sports
they've been successful due to the hard
work and dedication of their primary
link teacher louise back
louise continues to go out of her way to
ensure that the pupils at wallbrook
access
everything that the dartmoor schools
sports partnership offers
walbra prepares teams for competitive
events but also makes sure that all
pupils can access all the opportunities
relevant to them louise is never
deterred from the hard work that's
involved in ensuring that pupils access
these opportunities
she works hard to try and ensure that pe
is delivered across the school and is a
high standard
she promotes all training opportunities
luis has also had an impact as part of
the dartmoor schools sports partnership
management team steering the direction
and supporting the ssp louise makes sure
that her school also accesses local
facilities to support physical activity
out of school
they achieved their school games
platinum award which reflects the length
the school is going to to offer a range
of activities to each and every pupil at
the highest possible standard of
delivery the walbra pupils are lucky to
have louise at their school
[Music]
and the winner is sheldon primary school
so congratulations to them the dog's now
in the lounge as well so you won't hear
the patter of his paws
as he walks past the next category is
for our young persons services to sport
and community in recognition of a young
person
18 and under who's contributed
significantly to their community
in sport health or as part of education
school college and or community
the finalists are as follows zach ray
lindley moss josh lockwood
chloe and shannon whittle let's see what
they've all been up to
[Music]
[Music]
zach ray lindley moss four years ago
zach left ryden primary school and moved
on to newton abbott college most
children leave for good or may pop back
once in a while but zack
is very different ever since he left
ryden zach has returned on every
non-pupil day to help in classes
help with sports events and even help on
a saturday with fundraising events like
the summer fair
he always phones to arrange his visits
and is always punctual and incredibly
professional when in school
teaching staff welcome his support and
are always keen to have him in their
class
where zach really shines is in his
relationship with people he's confident
and enthusiastic and he makes a
difference in every role he takes on at
the school
he's an incredibly respectful young man
and is a tremendous role model to the
younger children
he's an absolute credit and is a real
community role model
[Music]
josh lockwood josh is an inspirational
role model for all the younger children
as well as his peers at bobby tracy
primary school he assists in leading
activities for younger children at
lunchtime
as well as in after school clubs making
a positive impact on these children to
help develop their physical ability
this year josh proved a bigger
inspiration for everyone at the school
throughout 2019 josh has been running
with his mum to raise money for the
brainchemist charity the reason he chose
this charity is because his granddad
died of a brain tumor
he and his mum had around almost 600
miles and josh had a target to cover the
940 landmarks between bobby tracy and
the north pole before christmas 2019.
therefore on the 18th of december josh
decided to challenge everyone in the
school to work together to help him out
and run the 300 miles left that there
was to go josh organized for all the
classes to go down to the school field
throughout the day to run for 30 minutes
at a time
clocking each lap against the map to
show their progress he also organized
for every person to have the opportunity
to raise sponsorship money toward the
brain tumor charity which raised a total
of 114
pounds chloe and shannon whittle
chloe and shannon are currently year 13
south dartmoor community college
students who go above and beyond
continuously and are simply fantastic
they're both hardworking and
conscientious students they're
exceptional role models they will
forever have their place on the south
dartmoor sporting honours board
throughout their time at south dartmoor
they both put themselves forward to
volunteer for a range of events across
the academic year the support they offer
the pe department goes above and beyond
students of their age
members of the learning community will
recognize them from all their efforts
umpiring netball with the dartmoor
school sports partnership
as well as coaching and leading events
ranging from handball festivals
to football tournaments for the younger
generations it's evident that whatever
the girls turn their hand to they'll
give it 100
and staff have lost track of the amount
of hours they've volunteered
[Music]
and the winner is josh lockwood
congratulations
to josh chloe shannon and zach and well
done for going above
and beyond for your schools
the junior sports person of the year is
next
this category is in recognition of an
individual who's achieved
local regional or national success
within their sport
from the 15th of september 2018 to the
15th
of january 2020 and the nominees are
charlie ryder emily churchill
hudson cooper thompson and let's find
out some more
charlie rider charlie is a boxer under
the amateur boxing alliance
boxing at local clubs in the area he's
boxed 10 bouts including six at national
level
one at regional level and three at club
level
charlie trains four times a week in the
gym as well as completing an
arduous training regime in his free time
in his boxing career he's the holder of
the london aba welterweight
belt and has won the novice national
title for two years in a row
not only is he dedicated to his own
development he also teaches boxing
skills to two younger students with
special educational and physical needs
at school he's been rewarded for his
commitment to sports by being awarded
the position of sports captain
and was also given the prestigious
community award from his school
for his work with younger members of the
community
emily churchill emily is an outstanding
athlete
she's ranked in the top 15 in the uk for
triple jump
she's achieved indoor and county
championship titles in long jump
triple jump 300 meters sprinting and
hurdles
representing both devon and the
southwest for various events
in 2019 she was also the regional
netball squad captain that led the team
to the nationals in may
she's won athlete of the year and
netball player of the year titles at
newton abbott college
in october 2019 emily was selected to
play for seven stars nova academy
part of mpl performance team training in
bristol twice a week
on top of this she won the tour bay
netball league defender of the season in
may 2019
team bridge titan sports woman of the
year and she was selected for under 16's
regional squad
emily continues to compete at an
extremely high level in two very
competitive sports and is certainly one
to watch on the international stage for
her triple jumping
hudson cooper-thompson hudson is three
times the uk
itf taekwondo national champion with
four gold medals
he was a double goal medalist at one of
the national championships and the
british taekwondo council's british
champion at the 2019 championships
he was a silver medalist at spanish copa
challenger championships in barcelona
double gold medalist at the southwest
open taekwondo championships
and a double gold medalist at the
cardiff inter club championships
and the winner is emily churchill
congratulations to emily
let's see what the senior sports people
have got
as we introduce the next category in
recognition of an individual
who's achieved local regional or
national success within their sports
from september 15 2018 to the 15th of
january
2020 the finalists for the
senior sports person of the year are as
follows
harrison wood sam
taylor rachel fee
james bevis let's see our nominees in
[Music]
action
[Music]
harrisonwood after a successful racing
season in 2018 he was second in the
national junior best all-rounder
competition
he was accepted by the amite de vela
club a on provence club in france
and he set off with a bag of clothes and
a new life in france he was put into the
b
team but within a month he was promoted
to the a-team he and the team raced all
around france
spain italy and luxembourg harrison was
often asked to work for older and
stronger team members sacrificing his
own chances
however his climbing prowess meant he
was able to assert himself and lead the
team to the overall team award
his best results came in spain when he
was on the podium for two of the four
stages
and ended up in second place overall he
impressed many teams and signed for a
dutch team in 2019
he gained a number of titles and
positions throughout the season
including 10th in the uk
national time trial in june sam taylor
sam has always been recognised as one to
watch on the hockey pitch and he's
certainly making a name for himself in
both the england and gb squads at a
national and international standard
during 2019 sam was selected for the
england under 18's hockey team that
played in both a three-test series in
the netherlands followed by an
under-18 six nations competition during
the six nations competition
sam made a fantastic contribution to the
team and they finished in bronze
position overall
after a successful season last year
representing england
and being involved in the promotion of
the men's ashmore hockey team
sam has gone on to represent the gb
under 23s and has been selected for the
great britain elite development
programme
in addition to this sam has gone on to
finish fourth top goalscorer in the
national league indoor division one with
ashmore hockey
rachael fee rachel has always been an
incredibly hard-working and dedicated
netball player
it came as no surprise when she was
selected for the england under-19 squad
whilst playing for bath under-19s
she then went on to be selected for the
summer england under-19 tour to new
zealand and australia
rachel's hard work and determination
resulted in her playing in the final mpl
tournament for bath under 21s and in
selection for the england under-21
summer camp and the long squad for the
netball youth world cup in 2021
she played in the europe squad in
october 2019 she continues to train with
the squad whilst also training with
super league the pinnacle of netball in
this country
rachel's selection into the final 15
bath super league squad is an
outstanding achievement
so far she's played in pre-season
tournaments and under 21 games with
super league beginning shortly
although south dartmouth were gutted to
lose her as a student they're proud to
hear that she is captain of her college
academy and should be leading them to
national college finals this year
on top of this rachel was always the
most supportive student of her
classmates and younger students helping
and encouraging them on the netball
court
she is a true role model james beavis
james is a former overall winner of the
teen bridge sports personality awards
for his rifle shooting achievements in
the paralympics at london 2012.
he continues to achieve in parachuting
events on a national stage with numerous
titles that include
gold for both individual and team events
at the shooting parasport world
championships
team silva in the r5 indoor 10-meter
rifle event
and team gold in the r9 outdoor 50 meter
taking fifth place in the shooting
parasport world championships in october
of 2019
and seventh place as well as team gold
at the same event
james is ranked at number two in the
world for r9 50 meter outdoor rifle
events and has gained its place in the
squad for the tokyo 2020 paralympic
games
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the winner is sam taylor
congratulations to
sam staying with the sporting theme the
team of the year award is up next
in recognition of a team that's achieved
local regional or
national success within their sport or
community from september the 15th 2018
to the 15th of january 2020
and here are the nominees bobby tracy jr
lifesaving team
mid devon youth cyclocross team
newton abbott rfc ladies team
let's see all their achievements to date
via our short
[Music]
presentation
bobby tracy junior lifesaving team the
team qualified to represent the south
west region at the national life-saving
championships held in leeds competing
against all the other regions in the uk
including the whole of wales scotland
and ireland senior girls were 9th
overall
junior boys were 9th overall and the
junior girls were sick overall in the uk
in the club simulated emergency rescue
competition the team came
sixth in 2018 and fourth overall in 2019
out of all the clubs in the uk
the results include third in the life
support initiative
12th overall in the uk third in aquatic
initiative
sixth overall in the uk and first in
aquatic initiative and third overall in
the uk this is a fantastic achievement
from a community-based club at a pool
only open in the summer months and
completely run by volunteers
mid devon youth cyclocross team the
youth team competed in the south west
cycle across a national league
throughout the 2019 season this young
team has riders from age 6 to 15
competing in 10 age groups across boys
and girls
this year saw eight mid devon cycle club
riders come together over 11 rounds
across the southwest to compete against
162 other riders in tough weather
conditions from 20 plus degree heat to
wind
rain and ice showing the wide range of
skills needed to handle 11 different
courses and conditions
the team saw all eight riders all
placing in the top five for their age
categories with two winning the series
for their age groups
the team also competed in the south west
regional championships
a one-off stand-alone event with even
more success picking up six medals and
crowning three south west champions
the course was a new venue and gave all
the riders a good challenge with gold
and silver medals for the under eights
and gold and fourth places for the
under-10s with a bronze medal and a
fifth place for the under-12s
under 16 boyce or calumstar right his
best race of the season taking on a
strong team of five dartmoor fellow
riders and coming out on top with a gold
medal
[Music]
newtonaba rsc ladies team in the 2018-19
season
this inspiring team was promoted to the
nc1 south west league
having won all their games the previous
season they finished the season in a
creditable second place
losing only to the league champions the
all whites ladies team are achieving
huge results and making their mark in
the world of rugby as they fly up the
leagues to prove themselves as players
and a united squad the current age range
of the ladies section is from 18 to 43
within this they have ladies who are
complete novices and players with 20
years of experience this season they
have won all their games so far
and are league leaders with three games
to go their dedication to their team
club and community
is outstanding
[Music]
and the winner is newton abbott rfc
ladies team many congratulations to
newton abbott
the next category is for business
contribution to sport
and or community in recognition
of a business that's contributed to
sport and or the community
through financial and or non-financial
means
from september the 15th 2018 to the 15th
of january
2020 and the nominees are
premier kickboxing newton abbott
waggle events limited horsemanship
for health let's see what they've done
to get this far
[Music]
premier kickboxing newton abbott
opened in october 2018 the team at
premier kickboxing have quickly
established themselves as a leading
family-driven martial arts club in the
uk
moving their family from london was a
huge risk for them both they knew no one
and have already established member
numbers in excess of 260 to date simply
through word of mouth
their involvement already in local
community projects is staggering
supporting numerous charities and events
they're heavily involved in
anti-bullying campaigns and work closely
with re-org who work with ex-service men
and women introducing them into martial
arts for their mental health and
well-being when medically discharged
from the service
without doubt premiere kickboxing newton
abbott has saved lives
many of us would now be completely lost
without premier kickboxing and this is
all thanks to stuart and neula mcdowell
who've given up everything for this club
waggle events limited waggle is a
business with a social enterprise
approach
they invest profits into subsidies for
charity clients to whom we offer
subsidised rates and a donation from a
profit share scheme since starting up in
2016 they've supported a variety of
local charities to help them host
fundraising events
by their nature community fundraising
initiatives tend to be sports based and
involve the coming together of large
groups of people
waggle sets out to help charities to run
events that are every bit as
professional and enjoyable to experience
as the most high budget corporate
functions
the profit share fund totaled just over
1500 pounds and was shared between
charities nominated by their corporate
customers
in february 2020 their profit share
figure has increased to over 2
800 pounds horsemanship for health
horsemanship for health is a community
interest company offering equine
assisted social education courses on a
farm in newton albert for adults and
young people with mental health
challenges
they've worked on a series of projects
with children from canada hill primary
school in newton abbott who are in need
of support
such as adopted children with special
educational needs and children who are
experiencing family challenges
most of the children receive one-to-one
support at the school and the farm-based
courses give the children a chance to
learn
in nature developing their social skills
self-awareness and confidence
the cic has also offered a series of
recovery educational courses in recovery
from mental health challenges such as
long-term depression
anxiety and domestic violence
and the winner is horsemanship for
health
next we have charity contribution to
sport and or community
in recognition of a charity or a
not-for-profit organization
that's contributed to sport and or the
community
through financial and or non-financial
means
from the 15th of september 2018 to the
15th
of january 2020. and here are the
nominees
andy mann's club mental health muscle
united
and age uk devon let's have a look at
the video
[Music]
andy mann's club andy mann's club was
set up in 2016 by luke amber following
the suicide of his brother-in-law he
felt that men needed an outlet to talk
and coined the slogan it's okay to talk
the group was originally set up in
halifax and grew to over 26 clubs
nationwide
in 2018 newton abbott was rocked by two
suicides of local young men
chris martin and adam fletcher decided
to set up a newton abbott branch of andy
mann's club
they now regularly have up to 50 local
men walking through the door at their
support group which is run every monday
the group has changed lives and
prevented many suicides in teen bridge
which remains the biggest killer of men
they volunteered their time for the
council's waste and recycling staff
trading days and this has resulted in
many of the staff seeking their support
and attending the club regularly
both adam and chris do this work
completely voluntarily and have
massively contributed to a change in
men's mental health in the community and
deserve recognition for the change they
have contributed to in supporting male
mental health
they've been instrumental in raising the
profile on men's mental health and
suicide prevention across newton ava and
surrounding areas and have since set up
the women's wellbeing group promoting
the it's good to talk message
and changing people's lives for the
better
mental health muscle united mental
health muscle united was set up in
celebration of kyle deakin's life a
young football player from kingston afc
who sadly took his own life in august
2018. the founder and chairman aaron
clark created mental health muscle
united to bring together his friends
and those struggling with their own
mental health and raising awareness of
mental health issues and suicide
prevention through football the
community teams supported by devon fa
have gone from strength to strength and
although very young are making
incredible impacts in the local area
whilst raising a hundred percent of
their funds to kingscare
do it for deek's campaign so far raising
nearly 3 000 pounds for them it's a true
credit to aaron who always seems to have
the vision to support
help and create such positive things his
support of matthew barrett as manager of
mhm united
is such a great one as one of carl's
closest and longest friends
he himself carries the same message as
aaron and the players all echo this
sentiment this really is an incredible
movement
kyle would have been so proud of all of
them and all they've achieved in raising
awareness of mental health in the
community
age uk devon age uk devon
strives to engage with older people to
encourage them to enjoy being active in
later life
and introduce them to activities and
sports through the can project and with
partner organizations
to provide opportunities for people to
embrace physical and mental health
and well-being and reduce isolation
through the various projects
programs and events that are delivered
the swim to the sea project started in
june 2019 and offered people age 55 and
over the opportunity to build skills and
confidence to enjoy
sea swimming the first six sessions were
pool based at timoth lido where the
participants trained for sea swimming
including swimming in wetsuits and
around boys and they built on their
confidence and fitness and skills
and the following six sessions were
based at timothe beach all sessions were
supported by pete wilby the swimming and
triathlon coach
trish warren the age uk devon active and
later life manager swimming coach
and can volunteers ambassadors and the
timmouth surf lifesaving club the
project was so popular
that a second project was set up
therefore they were known as waves one
and two as a result participants
increased their activity level
built on their open water safety
knowledge and swimming skills and made
great friendships and enjoyed social
meetings they continued to swim together
at the cannes winter wave sessions and
independently some of the groups are
even training to participate in their
first triathlon events and open water
events
organic art organic art is a small
charity running an arts and education
center
they work with creativity and land-based
learning to empower all people within
the community
encouraging a healthy and fulfilling
future
this year organic arts has worked with
nurseries local businesses
universities community groups ethnic
support groups
vulnerable adults teenagers facing
challenges
housing agencies people with learning
disabilities and more
they've engaged with over 4 000 people
in over 200 sessions
they planted vegetables made soup
pressed apples
woven willow explored the farm dug clay
made pots created sculptures ran
workshops
and held open days
[Music]
and the winner is andy mann's club
such an important message for supporting
men through suicidal thoughts and
encouraging us to talk thank you to all
our finalists and congratulations on
your achievements
the next category is always such an
impressive and inspirational moment in
the awards as we look to recognize the
lifetime
achievements of many of our local
residents who've devoted a huge amount
of energy
enthusiasm and volunteer hours to our
communities
the lifetime achievement award for sport
or community
is up next and here are the finalists
joan norman janet gorge
steve dinney sue hutchings
john campbell and here they are
joan norman joan is a veteran of the
voluntary sector
older than many of the people she helps
and is still very active in the
community having established a
befriending service
a coffee morning and helping to run the
weekly community lunch club having spent
her career helping others and being an
active member of her community in the
southeast of england she moved to
ashburton in 1970.
she started as part of the founding team
who established the volunteer driver
service in the town
attached to the local gp surgery whilst
volunteering as a driver for people
needing lifts to the surgery or hospital
she quickly spotted the need for
supporting people beyond their transport
requirements
social contact was also missing in their
lives and family relationships were
present were often not sufficiently
close to stop people feeling lonely
joan noticed this in 1995 when she first
volunteered with dash
in 1999 jones stepped in to develop a
visiting service and recruited others to
join her
eventually she would visit the ashburton
community hospital weekly to find out if
anyone there wanted a visitor or would
need support when they got back home
as well as taking on referrals from the
local gps at the same time she
established a community coffee morning
on a saturday morning
that has now been running for 20 years
and has been a weekend lifeline for
people living alone she remains a
trustee and driver of dash
host of the coffee morning as part of a
team a befriender to several regular
clients
a star wars driver and team member for
the weekly community lunch club and
an active volunteer befriender with
ashburton and buckfastly community care
which grew out of the befriending
service which joan established and which
today receives hundreds of referrals
from local gps and other health
professionals as well as family
friends and patients themselves the
service ashburton and buckfast league
community care offers is now an
essential part of the local health
and well-being services available to
people in these towns and provides a
fitting legacy for jones dedication and
service
janet gorge janet gorge became involved
with sheldon primary school in 1990
when she worked there as a dinner lady
alongside being a single parent
bar work and returning to education to
train to be a teacher
when she qualified in 1999 the school
was quick to snap her up as their year 3
teacher
she spent the next 20 years educating
and inspiring local children
with the majority of her career spent in
class six
children always looked forward to being
in her class as she had a fantastic
reputation for doing things like taking
them out at sunrise to do some artwork
during her time at the school her class
took part in other exciting projects
like building real boats from scratch
becoming pen pals with local
lonely and isolated people and going on
a tall ship's adventure
sadly janet was diagnosed with bowel
cancer in february 2018
and died in july this year during the
coronavirus pandemic
throughout her illness she stayed
involved with the school and continued
to inspire many people with her positive
and grateful attitude at the beginning
of the pandemic
she started a fundraiser for homeless in
teen bridge support
raising over 4 500 pounds for the food
bank
at a time when it was needed more than
ever
steve dinney teachers come and go they
can all leave their mark on their impact
some more than others but steve dinney
has well and truly left his mark on
south dartmoor not only has he led teams
in both hockey and cricket to national
finals and not only has he encouraged
students to become elite performers but
he's also inspired them to participate
at all levels
inspiring them to believe in themselves
steve has been the beating heart of
south dartmouth for so many years
and he is that to ashmore hockey club
also it will be virtually impossible to
find someone as committed and successful
and dedicated as he is
steve has volunteered for sport all of
his life for way over 30 plus years and
has made an impact on thousands of
children and young people in all that
he's done
he always goes the extra mile and has
made a huge impact on the local
community
he's been the team manager for team
bridges hockey teams at the devon youth
games since the first ever one in 1999
and he's continued to guide and support
thousands of new volunteers
coaches players and officials in his
spare time he's truly extraordinary and
deserves to be recognised for a lifetime
of achievements both in education
and across the sporting community of
teambridge steve has our utmost respect
what can we say about someone who's
missed so much now that he's retired you
can't actually appreciate just how much
anything that anyone can write or say
about steve simply cannot do him justice
he's one in a million sue hutchings
the name sue hutchings is synonymous
with sport among the bovi tracy
community the south dartmoor school
sports partnership the coaching world of
uk lions hockey and the local hockey
community and the royal life saving
society at both local and national
levels
here at bobby tracy primary we feel that
a nomination is a fitting tribute to
everything that she brought to the
school in the 18 years she worked here
and indeed to all those children in the
wider local community that she's
inspired in the past and who she
continues to inspire today
when she retired last year in july 2019
we brought her a t-shirt emblazoned with
the word legend
to us that says it all sue developed and
ran numerous school clubs including
netball
football athletics running and sessions
for children identified as talented and
able to cover nutrition and sporting
ethos
she regularly qualified to take teams to
summer and winter devon school games
thanks to sue we won too many trophies
and tournaments to mention but more
importantly she encouraged children to
participate in
and continue with health sports and
fitness in her spare time sue volunteers
at bobby tracy lifesaving club and iska
hockey club
and she's currently the head hockey
coach for uk lionesses and west panthers
sue has spent her life inspiring others
through sport and physical activity from
a local level
to national standard john campbell
lifetime commitment to community sport
but especially for his 30 years plus as
a player
chairman manager groundsman linesman
referee ender season tour organizer lead
spokesman
general champion and charismatic and
genuine friend of everyone who's ever
been associated with sheldon villa fc
jon is singularly responsible for the
club existing at all and long championed
the cause for changing rooms through a
decade or more of pitch side football
strip donning he's seen generations of
players come and go
remaining the one constant figure
through untold turmoil including loss of
key personnel
both on and off the pitch on numerous
occasions jon's dedication to sheldon
villa has meant an
important community hub has thrived for
all these years providing a form of
sanctuary or diversion from the humdrum
and sometimes much worse for the legions
of players who've been drawn to the
convivial and inclusive ethos and
environment engendered by john there are
a multitude of men
in timoth sheldon and beyond who owe
lifelong friendships to the commitment
of john
turning 70 last year his surprise party
was an emotional affair with hundreds in
attendance to pay their respects
attendees raged in age from 5 to 80 male
and female demonstrating the draw of the
man and cementing his status as a
community giant and genuine friend to so
many
all in all john has had a phenomenally
interesting life enriched by his
decades-long commitment to sport
in team bridge which in turn is
something which has positively
influenced so much and so many
in the area
[Music]
and the winner is janet gorge
sadly janet lost the battle of a
terminal illness during lockdown
and we're sending all our thoughts and
best wishes to everyone that knew her
and all that she did for the community
the final award of the night goes to a
very special person who
touched the hearts of the community of
king stanton
there are no finalists this was a
nomination that stood out to the judges
and was given his own title of the
bernard jones
lifetime award let's hear more about
what bernard achieved
bernard jones was the former youth
chairman of king stanton afc
and president of pioneer league on the
9th of december 2019
he sadly passed away after dedicating
his entire life to the local community
and king stanton afc
the impact he had on the local community
was evident across the whole of king
stanton when the news of his passing was
released bernard's involvement with
youth football started in the 2007-2008
season he got more involved and
eventually took on the role as chairman
there were two teams under 11s and under
sevens it was in the 2011 season when
the club amalgamated with the rams and
became king stanton athletic youth
football club
from there bernard and his enthusiastic
loyal team built the youth section
up to where it is now offering six teams
within the pioneer league
and currently giving over 100 local
children the chance to play and be
involved with a sport
from humble beginnings where the end of
season presentation in 2008 took place
on the grass banks of coach road to last
year's presentation
where the racecourse top bar was filled
to capacity with over 200 children
parents and committee members a meteoric
rise all under the chairmanship of
bernard which is a fantastic legacy he's
left but burn being burned didn't just
help the youth
he also took an active role with the
senior football always attending
committee meetings
and was a real practical help on match
days he soon endeared himself to all
club members
especially in the bar after a game no
one had a bad word for him
his smiling face was soon a fixture and
we all enjoyed his company
members of king stanton afc will always
remember him and had this to say
we've lost a passionate and lovely
person a truly magnificent man who loved
king stanton athletic youth football
club
he will be sorely missed by the family
that is the youth football community in
south devon
we're all hurting because you left us
too early but that is something none of
us can control
however i think it's worth us going
through the pain of our loss by us being
fortunate to have known you bernie
everyone loved you respected you and
that youth football in our area
has a lot to thank you for
[Music]
congratulations to bernard and the
legacy that he has left behind
with hundreds of local residents who
supported him in his dedication to local
sports
and the local community you'll be
forever
in their hearts i'd like to take this
opportunity to thank you
for watching the first virtual awards
evening brought to you by team bridge
district council
kitson solicitors the mid devon
advertiser
and the team bridge rotary clubs
we sincerely hope that you've enjoyed
the awards please make sure you like
share and comment across all social
media channels
and show your support for our finalists
this evening so from all of us
a very goodbye
you